a new study found cigarettes can
potentially release significant amounts
of toxic metals in its vapors which
users inhale scientists examined 56e
cigarettes they discovered a number of
them released vapors with potentially
unsafe levels of lead chromium manganese
and/or nickel now scientists and health
advocates are concerned about vaping is
growing popularity especially among
teenagers Anna Werner has the story
good morning east cigarette use and
vaping have been described as safer
alternatives to smoking cigarettes but
advocacy groups and some scientists
studying the growing trend say those
nicotine containing devices carry known
health risks to developing teenage
brains and some kids are already using
them a lot of people like these things
and we do too it's something you can
find teens posting about all over social
media vaping inhaling the vapors from
east cigarette products high school
sophomore Kyler crystal Pettis is one of
them when's the first time you tried
vaping when I was in sixth grade why did
you try it because my friend was doing
it government statistics found millions
of teens have tried it nearly 36 percent
of 12th graders had tried some form of
vaping in 2017 which included a
cigarette devices that can look like
cigarettes pens or USB data storage
drives everyone buzzes like everyone
every time I go into the bathroom
there's someone doing it now researchers
at University of California's School of
Medicine are raising concerns about
vaping zhh impact their studies show
some teens who likely would not have
smoked the regular cigarettes are using
e-cigarettes it also found teens who do
vape are 6 times more likely as those
who have never vaped to later begin
smoking scientist Jessica Barrington
trim is the normalization of e-cigarette
products and vaping products is really
problematic the vaping industry disputes
the study saying there's no
peer-reviewed science that establishes a
causal relationship between vapor use
and smoking initiation by minors do you
worry about what's in it honestly
No why not I don't really think about it
I just like it's just advertised as
being healthier than smoking cigarettes
some research does seem to support the
idea that e-cigarettes are less harmful
than regular cigarettes but a new study
from the NYU School of Medicine finds
that nicotine from ecig rets can cause
cancer in mice and the authors wrote
it's possible that e-cigarette smoke may
contribute to lung and bladder cancer as
well as heart disease in humans ecig
arete manufacturers say their products
are not aimed at children but Vince will
more with the nonprofit group campaign
for tobacco-free kids is skeptical there
are over 7,000 flavors of e-cigarettes
on the market including flavors like
gummy bear
cotton candy those are flavors that
clearly appeal the kids one brand that
has become particularly trendy is Joule
the company says its device which
resembles a USB Drive is now the number
one selling cigarette in the country one
pod contains as much nicotine as a pack
of cigarettes it's slick
its high-tech it looks like a thumb
drive on a computer which means you can
hide it easily and it gives a very
strong head of nicotine so this is about
an ideal tobacco product to get kids
hooked and do you think the companies
know that well if they didn't know it
when when they introduced a product on
the market they should know it by now
Krista peda says at his high school
dual products are everywhere even though
selling them to minors is illegal are
they hard to get no not at all not at
all so like you get them at school you
can put on your snapchat story who's got
a jewel and everyone has one and you can
just buy one so fast the company says
its products are not for kids
in a statement jewel said we condemned
the use of our product by minors we are
fully committed to dramatically reducing
the incidence of young people using
jewel the company says to that end it's
investing in significant resources and
personnel to combat the problem but some
kids clearly aren't listening on social
media the hashtag do it for jewel has
inspired many to post themselves and
others Julie
and Wilmore says as a first step the FDA
should ban the flavored products he says
kids are attracted to we'd like to see
the FDA exercised that authority the
vapor Technology Association says it's
working aggressively to push federal
legislation that would restrict
marketing and youth access to vapor
products the FDA does have the authority
to regulate e-cigarettes but last year
they delayed regulations that would have
forced some east cigarette makers to
seek the agency's approval for their
products and could have forced some
products off the market Gail hmm all
right Anna